blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman let's talk about something
we've discussed kind of anecdotally
before but not not big picture the tsa
says that they have confiscated a record
number of firearms from
airline passengers at airports this year
and you might be shocked to know that
only some of those confiscated firearms
belonged to republican congressman
madison cawthorne uh so only a partial
joke there he actually did get caught
trying to
um bring a bring a firearm on board
getting it through secure trying to get
it through security um just a few months
ago let's discuss the data
passengers are bringing a record number
of guns to the airport tsa says airline
passengers are bringing guns to the
airport in numbers never seen before and
it is a quote huge problem
security and law enforcement officials
are at the same time dealing with an
unprecedented surge in belligerent
passengers straining the systems
designed to ke designed to keep air
travel safe
we've had more incidences
where don't they mean incidents we've
had many we've had many more incidences
where there are passenger disturbances
both in checkpoints and onboard aircraft
that makes it more important that there
are no guns involved says tsa
administrator david pakoski
tsa reports catching 4 650 firearms at
checkpoints in the first 10 months of
the year a majority of which were loaded
folks loaded firearms in airports that
surpasses the full year record of 4432
from 2019 so we've still got the rest of
october
um as well as november and december and
were already several hundred firearms
beyond the record
with 11 weeks left in the year including
the busy thanksgiving and christmas
seasons the number will reflect an
american population that is increasingly
armed i think more people are carrying
weapons just generally across the
country and then whatever is happening
across the country we see reflected in
our checkpoints as a passenger i don't
want another passenger flying with me
with a gun in their possession
yeah
the agency is also finding guns at a
faster rate than it has ever experienced
during the lows of air travel during the
pandemic in 2020 transportation security
officers confiscated a gun from about 10
passengers every 1 million this year
they're finding 11 armed passengers in
every 1 million 80 percent 80 percent of
the firearms
were found
loaded
no checkpoint
no airport is immune from having
passengers try to carry guns through the
checkpoint it does occur occur more
frequently in again the states where gun
carriage is at a higher rate compared to
other states you know there are people
who react to these stories and in fact
republican congressman madison cawthorne
said exactly this when he was caught
the explanation was the justification
was it was an honest mistake
i didn't realize that the gun was in my
carry-on
that is
negligent action
if you don't know what what are the main
things about firearms
uh keep them unloaded
keep them safely stored and know where
they are
if you believe your gun is unloaded at
home
or unloaded
in your checked baggage and it's
actually loaded in your carry-on
that is negligence and you shouldn't
even have that firearm
um the the justification the excuse that
they use
is actually something for which they
should have the ability to have that
firearm removed if you can't keep track
of where your loaded firearms are you
don't have any business owning a gun
aside from anybody's views about the
second amendment or background checks or
whatever when you say oops
i didn't think the gun was in my
carry-on then you didn't know where it
was and that's negligence and it's
irresponsible gun ownership
not knowing where your gun is
um and it's a frequently used excuse but
it's not really an excuse it should
actually make us say whoa
we should we've got to look into that
more
the article goes on to say
firearm fines by tsa workers create an
inconvenience for flyers during a time
when more people are looking to travel
again yeah it's more than an
inconvenience it's actually a
sort of an existential threat
firearms 80 percent loaded
gun discovery slow checkpoint lines
trigger a local or airport police
response airline officials meanwhile are
asking airport police to be proactive
about spotting intoxicated or otherwise
agitated passengers who may spark an
in-flight disturbance yeah we've talked
about this as well
those unruly passengers are also at
previously unseen levels it's sort of
like a
pandemic induced psychosis that we're
seeing it is
it's it's wild what is happening at
airports
i've how many times have i flown during
the pandemic i guess three round trip
flights
and all of the stuff i saw at the u.s
airports part of it was at international
airports everything i saw at u.s
airports
um
there was wacky behavior
wacky behavior and this is this is by
the way beyond
just people playing fast and loose with
the mask rules like holding a glass the
entire flight
to be in the process of drinking and
keeping their mask down you know stuff
like that
i'm talking about just belligerent
people
drunk people
loud people people screaming um it's
it's not good it's not good what's going
on and certainly adding firearms to that
mix would only make it much much worse
i want to play a clip for you today
of a fox news guest sort of giving away
the game giving away the strategy when
it comes to the anti-mask protests uh
there's this guy david avella who's the
chairman of gopac gop
pac go pacquiao okay um he was a guest
on fox news
and he essentially admits to what these
wild protests are at school board
meetings what they're really designed to
do
and why they're being urged on by
right-wing media and right-wing
activists and strategists they want to
make public schools seem so chaotic that
parents will say i'm pulling my kid out
i'm going to send them to a private
school i'm going to send them to a
charter school it's similar to the
strategy around making the postal
service really not function properly
we'll get to that let's start with the
clip take a listen to this julie brought
to this conversation makes me think
maybe she'll run for school board and uh
we need something
so right now they're praising some
outrageous lunatic woman who was
screaming her mouth you know screaming
her head off at a
school board meeting teacher so i don't
know about that i actually elected to be
the class teacher to my sixth grader and
i don't know what i was thinking
look this is going to be a boon for a
boom for uh private schools for charter
schools for home schoolers who are going
to look for an alternative other than in
the public school and there are plenty
of wonderful organizations
out there that provide scholarships for
kids to go to uh charter schools and and
by the way it's entirely an apparatus
that takes money away from public
schools as well
what we're going to start seeing is once
again democratic politicians policies
are going to hurt the very people they
think they are going to help which is in
many of our poor and rural communities
all across this country
and
to jenna's point you ask most everyday
teachers they want to teach their kids
the basics
reading writing arithmetic so that
they're ready to go out and compete in a
world where
china is not teaching the agenda yeah
there's actually a question mark as to
whether the standard curriculum is
actually preparing our kids that
different question uh but he's saying
the quiet part out loud here he's saying
the choir part this has been the
republican agenda this has been the
desantis agenda for a long time in
florida as well
weaken public schools in favor of
corporate owned schools
charter schools private schools etc and
one way to do it is creating
requirements
that make the schools look bad either
through testing
standardized testing different things to
then say the school's not working let's
take money away let's give vouchers to
people who want to send their kids to a
private or a charter school instead so
you make the schools worse to then
justify making them even worse
this is a very
it's like a perfect opportunity
make it seem crazy parents hear oh my
god there's anti-mask protesters outside
of the school uh when my kids are
showing up and then there's anti-mask
protesters taking over the school board
this is too crazy i'm gonna send my kids
to a charter school to a private school
i'm gonna homeschool them remember
something like 70 percent of american
homeschooling is christian based
um and for religious and moral reasons
mission accomplished this this is
exactly the plan and the bigger picture
here
is privatization that's the bigger
picture destroy why do they want to make
the postal service function like crap
uh because then you can justify
eliminating it all together and saying
let's just let actual private industry
even though the postal service is an
independent enterprise under the purview
of the federal government they they
don't want the government doing stuff
right that's socialism when the
government does stuff it's socialism
even if it's just oversight of an
independent postal service so then
people go fedex they go ups dhl etc uh
damage the postal service to justify
private replacements damage public
schools to justify sending more money to
private schools and charter schools etc
and they now are making these anti-mask
protesters out to be martyrs or victims
or whatever the case may be um
and i'll just look at one clip of that
real quick this is also during the same
program
uh kennedy saying
you're going to be targeted
for passionately raising your voice
we need to focus on the basics
and that's not what's happening right
now
can i can i add something very quickly
emily
of course
you're more likely to be targeted and
charged by the fbi for raising your
voice passionately at a school board
meeting then you are for trying to set a
federal building on fire with people
inside in portland oregon
right they're basically saying
just protesting about masks is more
likely to get you treated harshly by law
enforcement
than antifa setting fires in portland
oregon that's the case that they want to
make the game here
is privatization david avella there sang
the quiet part out loud we we know what
they're doing and also it's the
moralizing and the engaging people with
the most controversial stuff they can
and right now masking and vaccination is
exactly what that is they're admitting
it they're telling us that that's why
they're doing it tuesday october 19th 6
p.m eastern time will be our live viewer
town hall it'll be streaming only on the
second youtube channel pacmanlive at
youtube.com
pacmanlive
everybody will be allowed to call in
members will get priority but it'll be
wide open to everybody i hope you'll
join us
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
remember that the david pakman show does
depend on the
uh
few of you comparatively speaking who
get a membership at joinpackman.com you
can sign up become a member support the
show and of course
get instant access to the daily bonus
show for members only
sign up at joinpacman.com
let's speak to some people from the
audience we now take calls via discord
davidpakman.com
slash discord
um you can uh use discord to chat with
other viewers and listeners and also to
talk to me all right let's start today
with
tyler
from st louis tyler from st louis you
were on the air
hey what's up how you doing
i'm doing good good
um
so the question i want to ask is
what is the path here going forward for
like the progressive caucus because
in many ways i feel like
you know burn it all down everything
like that but then the other thing is
it's like
how
how long is it how long can they keep it
up before it starts hurting us
before what starts hurting us
oh the infrastructure um deal
you're saying it not being passed
yeah oh oh oh
yeah i mean listen um i think i don't
think
that the progressive i think there are
some people within the progressive
caucus who really are like burn it down
type accelerationists i don't think the
progressive caucus in general
is going to ultimately say no deal if
it's not a perfect deal i think the
progressive caucus overall
understands you really can't let the the
uh
a perfect be the enemy of the better
than what we have
and i think ultimately if it doesn't
happen it's it's really going to be
because of republicans but are you
you're you're thinking that it might be
the progressive caucus that actually
prevents infrastructure from being done
um no it's just kind of like how i
personally feel about it like
i'm like split you know
um
i mean i understand compromise and
everything like that yeah but
the thing is is
you know the deal is being broken
tyler are you eating something while you
talk to me
yeah sorry about that you are what are
you eating out of curiosity
uh just a sandwich sandwich okay all
right good um okay listen tyler i
understand your concern i don't think
progressives are ultimately going to be
the roadblock for the infrastructure
bill
yeah sure yeah
all right i'm going to let you go your
discord's blinging now lots going on
over there i'm going to let you get back
to the sandwich which seems delicious
quite frankly
why don't we go next to
oh i don't know it's so hard to know
where to go
what about sam from new york city
hey how are you doing um
oh i just wanted to ask i know in the
past um i don't know if it was a year or
two ago maybe you had stephanie kelton
on
i was just wondering if
you know with
maybe some of the recent stimulus
packages you've reconsidered your
feelings towards mmt or just sort of
what your general sense is towards
modern monetary theory yeah my my
generals
we've interviewed stephanie a couple of
times my general
uh perspective on modern monetary theory
right now is that
modern monetary theory makes a few
important points that should be
considered one
um a government and country's budget
is not analogous to a household budget
it's not and so we have to use different
terms the analogies and the comparisons
to a household budget
don't make sense because households
can't
change the money supply that's number
one number two
modern monetary theory makes a fantastic
point which is known outside of mmt as
well
that different types of deficit spending
are differently stimulative depending on
what you're spending the money on that's
the the second important thing
beyond that i'm not yet of the mindset
that the government can do absolutely
anything to the money supply with no
impact whatsoever i don't think that's
what modern monetary theory is saying
but there are people who think that
that's what it's saying and i think that
has not at all been been demonstrated so
that's
that's kind of where i am on mmt right
now
yeah that's fair and i think i agree
with you i don't think real people who
have studied modern monetary theory
would say it's just about spending as
much as you want without consequences
it's basically like
i guess my understanding is you can
spend as long as the resources are there
um as long as the physical and human
infrastructure is there to take on
whatever spending then you can pretty
much spend as much as you want because
you won't have excess
money chasing
scarcity of goods or resources as long
as you have enough resources i just
i guess my problem is i mean
i
just read stephanie kelton's book and
still don't think i have a
firm understanding of mmd
um and so
i wonder like i just think politically
you know not that we're anywhere close
to democrats promoting modern monetary
theory really but i think there is so
much promise in it but it would take a
complete restructuring of the framework
of how we discuss deficits oh yeah and
remember that the the debt and deficit
political football
is one that both republicans and
democrats toss around to different
degrees
it's the republicans who claim to care
about the deficit and then blow it up
like it's not a both sides thing in that
sense but both parties still
benefit from a lot of the discourse
around debt and deficit and that makes
it hard to break the fact that that's
how they're operating
yeah
one thing i've
thought about is you know
states um don't have the same freedom to
deficit spend because they're not
producing their own currency but if they
could produce their own sort of currency
i wonder if progressive states
i don't think this is constitutional but
i think it'd be an interesting
experiment if let's say california
created its own sort of currency could
then deficit spend implement some of the
policies in that mp and be able to fund
pretty substantial government projects
yeah that that's that's seeming a little
out there and unlikely as far as i'm
concerned right now but yeah yeah yeah
no it's an interesting idea
all right my friend thank you for the
call i appreciate it
thank you so much all right
um davidpakman.com
discord is how you can jump in and talk
to me
let's speak next to
geo from juarez
hello there
yes
hey uh i'm from mexico
and i also wanted to elaborate from the
last time um
eric from cancun called about the el
paso shooting
and how
i'm also a bit worried about what could
happen in in the
if i go to the us
okay
uh you see i'm from paris i'm from the
border of mexico and uh it's it's really
worrying to me sometimes because i used
to travel a lot to the u.s before the
pandemic actually the international
bridges have been closed since march
2020 and and they will open for the
first time in november this year
supposedly so i am also a bit worried
about if i should be ready for for a
shooting or something
okay well i mean listen it's just about
your personal risk assessment uh i would
research where you're going and
determine whether
it's suitable for your level of risk i
mean i i can't possibly answer the
question is it safe for you to go to the
u.s you know
yeah because you know you see the the
shooting that that happened in in el
paso in the walmart is actually a
walmart uh me and my mother used to go a
lot
and actually i i we didn't plan to go on
the day that it happened
but um
a friend was there a friend of mine he
said he he
didn't stop for anything but he just
gotta have little ptsdn and as and
scared of loud noises i don't know if
that's still the case but yeah it's a
bit worrying i just wanted to share that
yeah i mean listen you're the the odds
of you being killed in a shooting are
very very low although still higher than
in many other countries right so so you
know it's a very personal decision
okay well i just wanted to to ask your
opinion on that
yeah it's really it's i can't possibly
advise you on that
i see
all right my friend thank you very much
for the call
let's go next to hunter from colorado
hunter you're on the air
hey david how you doing i'm doing well
thank you
uh so i wanted to ask
what do you think invited the news that
william shatner and all these
guys are wanting to go to space do you
think
that that's actually important at all or
do you think
it's just a pissing contest do you think
they're doing it for the good of
humanity or just themselves i think i
think it's both i i think it doesn't
really matter why they are doing it i
am confident
that the things we will learn
from developing
space exploration technology
will benefit humanity now whether that's
why jeff bezos is doing it and elon musk
or really it's just kind of you know
just a competition among rich rich
people
uh is up for debate uh could be a little
bit of both
but i think that it's still going to
benefit us in terms of technological
development but in terms of like is it
important that william shatner
personally you know go up on the second
launch um
not really i mean you know it i guess
you could say there's more attention
paid to it when prominent people are
involved but i don't really think it
matters if william shatner goes up i
mean the the tough thing about this is
all of this stuff is a combination it's
a combination of rich dudes wanting
attention
fascinating technological development
what rich people do when they're not
sure how to spend their money it's all
of the above it's all it and so you
can't divorce any of this stuff from the
fact that hey you know maybe if some of
these
corporations and rich people really paid
the taxes that are their fair share
maybe they wouldn't have as much money
to do all this stuff but but they
probably still would have enough they
wouldn't have as much but they'd
probably still have enough and um it
would be the right thing to do morally
in terms of making people pay their fair
share but that doesn't mean it's a bad
thing that this is what they're doing i
a lot of people just want to be very
black and white like is this good or is
it bad very few things are so simple in
life
yeah yeah i'm totally in agreement i
think it
brings a lot of attention to space
travel and the importance of it but
at the end of the day i think they're
kind of mainly doing it to benefit
themselves and kind of
get investors to
throw more money at them so yeah i mean
listen in a very you know to take a very
kind of dark approach to it
eventually earth will not be habitable
anymore right the sun is going to expand
and consume the earth
so
at a certain point if humanity wants to
continue we're going to have to be able
to go somewhere else and so if the first
people to start pushing us in that
direction or some of the early people do
it because they want fame or money
okay i mean that's why they do it but at
a certain point it's something humanity
would need to do
i agree
let's get there all right thank you very
much appreciate the call
an important topic for sure
let's go next to steph from wisconsin
steph you were on the air
hey david thanks for taking the call
pleasure i have two questions okay so
the first one is um
i don't know if you've seen the new data
from the fda but they claim or sorry
about the madonna's booster
and i know that you got majirana so i
was wondering if uh you were planning on
getting the booster so steph if i if i
read the i only glanced at an article
but correct me if i'm wrong what they
said is
they are not really taking a position as
to whether moderna recipients should get
a third shot that two shots remain
effective against uh serious illness and
death but it's sort of up to the
individual to decide
exactly yeah yeah i haven't made a
decision to be honest about a third shot
yet
okay yeah i don't know i mean it's uh
i i i'd gladly go and get one you know i
don't have any problem with getting a
third shot i felt pretty lousy after
both my first and second shots i would
go and get one
it's just not
yet clear to me that
i should be the next person doing it i
don't know i really don't know
yeah it's
a tough it's tough thing to decide
um and so the second one kind of in the
same vein uh have you seen the data
suggesting that the flu shot boosts the
coveted vaccine efficacy and would you
consider doing a segment on it
i have not seen that and i absolutely
would consider doing a segment on it if
you can if you can email some of that
data to info at davidpakman.com that so
the argument is you get a flu shot and
it makes the covet vaccine more
efficacious
right i don't want to mistake it
because i haven't done like a deep dive
into it um
and so
that's what i was just curious about
that's what how i understood it yeah no
i'm finding articles i'm finding studies
which say
flu shot linked to less severe covid19
but we have you know there's a big
correlation causation thing we have to
look more about you're not wrong that
there are such reports i'd want to look
into them more
okay okay awesome i will definitely send
those to the email all right thanks
steph appreciate it
yeah thank you all right steph from
wisconsin coming in with some meaty
topics
let's take a quick break we're going to
keep taking calls so don't go anywhere
don't hang up if you're holding on to
talk to me we're just going to take a
very very quick break
and then go right back to the phones
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
all right let's keep hearing from folks
in the audience via discord you can chat
with me
via voice right now at davidpakman.com
discord
we are going to go next to marcus from
sacramento marcus you're on the air
uh thanks for taking my call dave
pleasure
so my question is in regards to uh
republicans moving forward on the
national scale um it seems as though
republicans are able to basically push
trump's agenda without the pushback that
trump would get because trump was such a
polarizing figure the first person that
comes to mind is like a ron desantis
um so i guess my overarching question is
can republicans basically be trump light
without um
without the ramifications trump would
have and secondly who do you think gets
the republican nomination in 2024.
second part i have no idea too much too
much still to to see we we must have the
2022 results before we can really think
seriously about 2024 but on your first
question the answer is absolutely yes
and it's dangerous i've talked before
about how someone like ron desantis who
has all of the same kind of immoral or
amoral instincts of donald trump
a lot of the radical ideology but is
less cartoonishly unhinged he's still
unhinged he just just less cartoonishly
unhinged
he may actually be able to do a lot of
the things trump merely wanted to do but
failed to do so you were absolutely
correct that the trump
uh agenda to the extent that it is an
agenda and it's kind of not right but
but to the extent that it's an agenda
um
it would be far more likely to be
carried on by people
less cartoonishly
uh problematic and ron desantis is a
perfect example of such a such an
individual
uh just one last follow-up do you think
desantis has a chance in 2024 to be the
nominee or to become president
uh both i think to be the nominee
yes although it depends a lot on whether
trump runs
and to become president
yeah i mean listen
look look at the country who that
elected elected trump in 2016. so
certainly this is a country that
would be ignorant enough to elect
desantis president yeah it's very very
scary
that's that is scary but thank you david
my pleasure thank you for the call very
much appreciate it
let's go
next so many folks uh chatting uh here
today
let's go
to
um
cooper
from colorado cooper you're on the air
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
fine yeah
awesome a huge fan of the show i wish i
had a question i always think of some
but never writing down but just want to
say i think it was last week or two
weeks ago you had a mustache i thought
it looked excellent sir oh thank you yes
i may i may do it again i was i was um
asked to get rid of it before this
wedding i went to over the weekend i was
told it would be really embarrassing for
everybody involved for me to show up at
the wedding with a with a mustache but
i'm gonna i'm gonna get it going again i
think
awesome hopefully no shave november
exactly all right thanks cooper
very good and there cooper has come and
gone
let's go uh where do we go next it's
tough to after that it's hard to know
let's go to andrew from menlo park
andrew you're on the air
hey david uh can you hear me i can
you're a little low but i'm going to
bump you up go ahead
okay
i'm my i i've been wanting to ask you
this for a little bit it's not really
related it's kind of related to politics
but
um with the kind of skyrocketing uh
housing prices seeming not to really
down very much and first-time buyers
really kind of
basically being completely shut out of
the market from my generation i'm a
millennial i'm 30 years old
um
what can the government do to
help with that situation or is is buying
a house just gonna be
a wealth generation tactic for
my age who basically just inherit from
their parents or
just can't buy at all and they just
end up being renters for life a lot of
unknowns there first of all any answer
there's not one answer to your question
about how the housing market because
there's multiple markets and the answers
are going to be extremely regionalized
there are parts of the country where
housing is still far more affordable
than others
and there's still a question as to with
more remote work potentially becoming
permanent
whether you're going to see a shift from
folks earning
okay salaries in big cities going to
cheaper areas and being very well
positioned to buy homes there of course
that will raise the value of real estate
in those
second or third tier areas so all of
this is is a lot of moving parts
um but
i've been reading a lot about this and
there there are people who believe that
these high housing prices are
essentially here to stay
if that's the case it's going to make it
really difficult for a lot of young
people including people still paying off
student loans to be able to buy homes
and you can make the case that that's a
really really bad thing particularly
when for so many households
their home is the number one driver of
net worth and without that savings and
net worth are dramatically impacted i
just think there are too many unknowns
and much like with the question of like
where's the stock market going to be in
two years or in five years
we are terrible at predicting this stuff
so i think anyone telling you anything
definitive in answer to these questions
they're just guessing and you should you
i think we just do not yet know
uh and particularly with work from home
there's people who say we're gonna see
like a nationalization of uh
of housing markets of course san
francisco is still going to cost more
than than tulsa right
but that there's going to be less of a
gap that may be the case we may see
things going a different direction i
just think we don't yet know but there's
no question that it presents massive
difficulties for people particularly
young people
paying off student loans at this time
well you don't think that
[Music]
as far as the question about what
government can do you think that they
should just there'd be no government
intervention and that maybe the market
corrects itself
i'm fine with government involvement in
affordable how and
now when i say affordable housing i
don't mean literally housing designated
affordable housing units but in making
housing affordable i have no moral issue
with government involvement i think that
that's fine
i'm just not sure
exactly what that involvement should be
because much of the idea around what
that involvement should be conflicts
um so i have i'm fine with there being a
role for government i think it could be
a good thing maybe it's state government
maybe it's federal government but i
would want to be real clear as to what
that involvement should be and it's not
exactly clear to me right now
okay thanks for yeah it just seems like
the government's really involved on one
side of the
aspect of
driving housing prices
they're kind of supporting
current homeowners being able to stay in
their houses therefore kind of creating
more you know less supply less you know
it just seems like they're involved in
propping up the housing market rather
than kind of having prices down yeah i
mean you know government's very involved
in the regulation of mortgages at least
the ones govern fannie mae freddie mac
that's another area where government's
already involved you could argue that
that's not really made housing more
affordable uh but yeah i have no problem
with government involvement i just want
to feel good that that government's
being involved in a productive way
thank you appreciate it all right thank
you for the call very much appreciate it
a lot of great questions today very much
appreciate it
uh why don't we go next to aaron from
los angeles erin you're on the air
hello david um i know you briefly
mentioned this before but i was
wondering if you're ever planning on
doing i i i wouldn't blame you if you
don't do it but like a deep dive on
misinformation in uh
foreign uh communities particularly the
uh latino community in the united states
because uh i've noticed especially
around like the long beach
linwood downey area of la county that
there's a lot of um
just misinformation and propaganda
that's getting spread and uh spanish and
spanish-language television is
definitely no assistance to that it's
usually just fear-mongering on most of
the major networks like univision so i
was wondering if there
if you were ever or if you know of
anybody that has done studies
on the effect of this type of
misinformation in those communities
i don't know of studies and it's a very
important topic i sort of met this head
on when i did i think it was like a 12
or 14 episode uh
election related show in spanish on the
estrella network which is sort of like a
competitor to univision but much much
smaller they're only on a you know a
small number of markets and i was
genuinely shocked at the reactions and
part of the confusion is
overall the american latino community is
pretty left i mean cubans are more
right-wing some venezuelans are more
right-wing
but for the most part part the american
latino community is pretty left
and yet there was a ton of like vaccine
disinformation and other things i told
my stories of when i was in miami a
couple months ago and like multiple uh
cuban uber and lyft drivers were talking
about becoming magnetized from the
vaccine and all sorts of conspiratorial
stuff that's anecdotal but but it goes
to what we're talking about here um i
think it's a great topic for a deep dive
i don't know if we'll do it maybe we
will i don't know if we have the the
bandwidth right now but it is a massive
massive issue and it should be talked
about and you know you've got i think
some people hesitate to talk about it
because it feels like they're sort of
like attacking hispanic people or being
xenophobic or whatever you know i'm from
argentina i'm an immigrant from
argentina i'm part of that group
culturally uh it's it's just a reality
there's a lot of that misinformation
that's spreading and part of it i think
is
that there are not enough counterpoints
that are available which is why i tried
to have a counterpoint with that short
run show that i did in spanish uh but
yeah a major problem you're completely
right in identifying it as uh it's
exactly as you describe
yeah it's yeah i i honestly don't think
there is like a fair counterpoint and
even though like i do agree that many
latinos tend to be left i feel like the
culture
especially i don't know just from my
perspective as a mexican-american is
very conservative from like a religious
aspect yes it's not even just
catholicism anymore like the evangelical
movement within the latino community has
been exploding in this country and i
feel that like that's really like that
is kind of another toxic thing within
itself yeah even though voting
wise
american latinos tend to vote for
democrats
um
there's a lot of cultural conservatism
that remains and and maybe that's part
of the issue that leads to the
disinformation spreading you i think you
you're probably on to something there
well thanks david my pleasure uh very
important topic appreciate getting the
opportunity to
uh chat about it with you
why don't we hear
next from
how about mario in turkey mario you're
on the air
oh hey hey can you hear me yes i can
hey um actually i'm from the united
states i'm deployed in turkey right now
but um i'm just gonna say i really don't
really have a question but it's i never
really thought that i was gonna be
called on i just wanna say uh i've been
watching you for about five years and
remember for about five years now and i
i think you're doing absolutely
wonderful work and keep it up thank you
i appreciate the kind words and the
support
yeah can you tell us what you're doing
what are you doing in turkey can you
tell us anything
uh yeah um i i fix something i fix
planes i work planes on an electrician
for
uh a kc-135
just a big uh tanker tanker jet so it's
like if it's if it's not classified
what's like a typical electrical problem
on a kc-135 that you'd have to fix
uh yeah i don't know if i can really say
that wow that even even even what the
problems are is potentially classified i
mean it's i mean you could no it's i
it's just yeah everything that we work
on
it's not like it's not like a super big
deal because i mean turkey has these
same deaths but like i don't know for
sure so
wow i'd just rather i just rather not
you know let me put it this way let me
ask a different question if you can
answer this one does being a regular
home electrician transfer in any way to
being an electrician for airplanes as a
general question
as a general question yeah i'd say uh i
don't i don't have any experience in
that but i mean
a ground is still a ground and you know
if you're getting power to a component
you're still you know like that
component should be working right got it
and being deployed in turkey
is your is your time spent like uh
basically on a base or are you out in
the communities at all
oh no yeah we're
my i haven't been off the base since i
got here and i've been here for
almost two months now so they don't they
don't let us because just because the
proximity of like
the enemies in the area they say
i don't know how true it is but they say
um
you know there's like terrorists out
here and i'm sure there's probably
people that don't like us but you know i
think from their standpoint it's just
better safe than sorry wow so you
literally do not leave the the the base
i haven't left the base in two months
and yeah they don't
yeah it's tough
can you even get like will they bring in
local pistachio baklava for you or are
you not even able to get it yeah oh yeah
no yeah we have like uh the locals like
they have their
their businesses out here and on base so
it's like but i mean i guess i've talked
to some of the locals before and they
say that their food is like americanized
so that we can you know it fits our
palette i said that kind of sucks you
know because i i kind of want you know i
want to try traditional food but yeah
it's not exactly
yeah i gotcha
all right my friend thank you for the
call i appreciate it
yeah thanks keep it up all right thank
you there is mario from turkey
you can get
turkish pistachio baklava on the base
really really important issue which i'm
glad we were able to get to the bottom
of that's gonna do it for today thanks
to everybody who called in apologies i
was not able to get to everybody
but we'll take calls again we'll we will
do it again if i have anything to say
about it
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com david pakman show all
right let's get into this week's mailbag
you can write in info
davidpakman.com um i i should say after
the deluge and some angry emails last
week the number of emails we get far
exceeds the five to ten that i can look
at
uh during the mailbag segment we get a
few hundred emails every day uh multiply
that by seven days a week you can
quickly see
why we can't get to all of them so info
davidpakman.com but emailing is no
guarantee that uh your email will make
it into the mailbag let's start with
today's first emails from chris chris
says hey david hope you're well what if
democrats or left-leaning people started
up a foe right-wing party in order to
steal votes from the republicans it
might be hard to pull off the lie to
make it seem authentic but politics is a
dirty game after all
if they could divert votes then mission
accomplished if they actually win then
mission accomplished just something i
was musing over for a bit of fun you
know i'm not totally sure that that's
legal there was this case actually i
think it involved i think it's still
going on it involves matt gates in
florida
about the idea of him being involved in
supporting like a
sort of diversion candidate uh and and
this is exactly the idea that chris is
pointing out i think that there's some
legal issue with it actually although i
don't remember exactly what it is
um i don't really have
a moral problem with it um
in in a sort of traditional sense
but i question whether it would really
work and at the end of the day
obviously if it's against the law then
it shouldn't be done
but even if it's not i'm just not sure
that a fake
right-wing party
would really work
other than maybe in a few districts but
i'd be willing to think about the
logistics a little more and and maybe
i'd have my mind changed on that
uh kevin wrote in
kevin says
this is a video clip that aired on cbs
morning news a month ago the story is
about the debate on requiring children
to wear masks in school or not
at 2 34 into the video a frustrated
parent says to the school board science
is not fact science is meant to be
challenged keep up the great work david
enjoy your youtube channel
here's this is this is actually a very
interesting topic
um increasingly you hear from people on
the right things like
science has been wrong
and you have to be allowed to challenge
science
both of those statements are true
but you've got to challenge science with
science and
contrary to like this is what makes
science different than religious beliefs
in most organized religion as well as in
cults
you're not rewarded for challenging the
orthodoxy and the teachings of the
pastor cult leader whatever
science on the other hand first of all
has a self-correcting mechanism where
hopefully we can duplicate results we do
more studies and there's also pretty big
financial and fame rewards if you were
able to disprove some major
accepted theory in science but you've
got to do it sorry as i hit my mic
you've got to do it with science and so
simply coming in and saying well i
challenge the science of vaccines with
my opinion that they do this or that
they do that or my pastor's feeling that
they do this and that
it's absolutely true that science is
meant to be challenged the scientific
method includes such a framework for
those challenges but that doesn't mean
anyone's opinion is just as valid of a
challenge or alternative to the accepted
scientific view so often with these
people there's like this kernel of truth
but it's completely misunderstood and
misapplied
more people continue to write in about
the trump flu pandemic thing uh 1917 flu
1918 flu as many of you know donald
trump started saying the 1917 flu even
though it's 1918 and he kept saying it
some people said oh no he's saying 17
because 17 is the 17th letter in the
alphabet i'm sorry q is the 17th letter
in the alphabet it's a signal to q anon
at wrote in and has a different idea and
says sir
your
1918-1917 flu analysis being a product
of trump's narcissism got me laughing
that's my theory on why trump eats
well-done steaks with ketchup when asked
sir how would you like it cooked would
you like it rare medium well done trump
answered not understanding the question
of course i want it well done like
correctly done
and that same narcissism prevented him
from sending his dry steak back to
partially remedy his predicament
he used ketchup because it was there
when asked why he declared it's how he
always eats his steak i wish this were
true but the simpler explanation may be
a burnt steak with ketchup most
resembles his favorite hamburgers
anyhow thanks for bringing some sanity
to the world appreciate what you do yeah
i think there's a lot to that not that
this is like the most important issue
but i do think often with trump
it's like when he started saying plasma
instead of plasma
and maybe someone went to him and said
it's plasma and he was like no no no i
say plasma maybe nobody did and he has
no uh awareness that he may be saying
something wrong but i think that the
narcissism is a more likely thing than
it's a signal to cue he called it the
1917 flu
maybe someone corrected him or he
certainly must have seen it on the news
but he decided now i i call it the 1917
flu i think that that's a very plausible
uh scenario
next email today is from chris
chris this is very interesting chris
says david
i live in texas
and identify as a republican but frankly
i'm embarrassed to be one at this point
in time
it seems a large number of republicans
currently in office don't live in
reality i believe as long as our
lawmakers have the us versus them
mindset
they will never come together for the
good of the people
it is time for the american people to
get off the couch and vote to remove
these stagnant lawmakers and replace
them with individuals who will put the
people first is it time to form a common
sense party i enjoy the show and
appreciate you shining a light on things
no matter what side of the fence they
are on listen i have no problem with
the idea the the idea of a common sense
party has been floated many times before
to some degree i think it's kind of what
andrew yang is trying to do with the
forward party andrew sent me his book
and we're trying to get him on the show
for an interview soon
but often what you end up with in these
situations is that there will be some
seemingly reasonable people from the
right like chris
who might be good faith participants in
such a common sense party
but very quickly you realize the vast
majority of those people
don't really have any common sense
and you can't really involve them
because their ideas are terrible
and they're not willing to have their
minds changed and so there's really no
practical way that you can include them
and that's what we often end up
uh sort of bumping up against for lack
of a better term and so i love the idea
i would love to be able to say hey you
know what if we keep the left
but then we include just like the same
right then on average we'll have a more
reasonable
there end up being we end up with very
few people like chris who we can
actually include and then then what you
end up risking is
it appeals to more democrats than
republicans and just hurts democrats and
leads to republicans being elected due
to being a spoiler and that's a disaster
that is not something i can
like in good faith really support if
it's going to even further sink the
country
into the bad
so
send me your thoughts i mean is my is my
analysis too negative too pessimistic
let me know
elizabeth wrote in
about americans refusing the covet
vaccine
for religious beliefs
elizabeth says david hopefully you can
clear this up for me
i recently saw on the news a woman who
was upset because she was threatened to
be removed from the kidney transplant
list because she refused to get a covet
vaccine stating religious belief
what religion would prohibit vaccination
but allow an organ transplant i believe
this is just an avenue people are using
to stronghold their refusal to get the
covet vaccine can you shed light on this
love listening to your show thanks for
what you do yeah i don't have a specific
answer but it's a gr it's a good
question which is
the religions that tend to be
just skeptical of medical treatment like
christian science is one where i once
knew someone who
um worked with a christian scientist who
said listen if i were to like get hurt
or it was a kind of a more dangerous job
you can't just call an ambulance you've
got to call my pastor
the pastor needs to first pray for me
and authorize
what needs to happen including whether
the ambulance can take me or whatever i
ass i don't know but it would seem to me
if an organization like that
would have as much of a problem with
organ transplants as as much as the
vaccine or there would be some kind of
double standard
i don't actually know are there
religions where an organ transplant is
okay but vaccination really is not okay
i'm not aware of them my instinct is
that elizabeth is probably
on to something here and that so-called
religious objections to vaccination
um are often just ways to
try to stop conversation
it's sort of like you know the right
likes to say when the left doesn't like
a conversation they go that's racist and
everybody goes oh and gets scared and
backs away from the conversation
similarly
um
i think that
my religion says i can't get vaccinated
um could could be used similarly here's
another interesting vaccine question
this one's from michael michael says hey
david when i hear all these anti-vaxxed
people incorrectly scream about gene
therapy what michael's referring to is
some people say
the mrna vaccines aren't vaccines
they're gene therapies michael says when
i hear them scream about that i wonder
what's wrong with gene therapy i'm not
an expert on the subject but isn't gene
therapy how we would eventually cure
such diseases as cancer diabetes and
dementia to name a few i always thought
of gene therapy as the holy grail of
medicine relating to longevity just
wanted to share that thought yeah i mean
listen i'm not an expert on that so i
don't i shouldn't really comment
specifically but this
reminds me of the entire the vaccine
makes you magnetic it magnetizes you do
we know for sure that being magnetized
is bad and what i mean by that is it's
sort of a joke but
have the anti-vaxxers who say the
vaccine magnetizes your arm or your
whole body have they said why it's bad
to be magnetized
understanding the problems with metal
implants and mris you know we could we
could imagine some some reasons but the
point is they don't really ever say that
they just say well it it's it's it's
this and therefore it's assumed to be
bad is it bad if the vaccine worked via
gene therapy
maybe that's okay as long as it protects
you from serious covet and death so very
very good point
um from mike there and then here's a
little bonus for you this one's from
youtube
this is just wild
someone wrote to me and they said
reread the fda website
idol approved for eau not eua eau or oh
the word for water in french
emergency use authorized requiring
madonna
j j
pfizer
you paid opposition remember it's the
anti-vaxxers getting paid not the people
reporting the science
but i did not know
that the fda was now by emergency use
requiring madonna songs be played i find
that extremely authoritarian if people
don't like madonna they shouldn't be
forced to listen to madonna i think that
that's absolutely absolutely horrible
obviously this is just riddled with
misspellings they met moderna by madonna
they meant eua rather than eau
oh boy
oh boy this is um
you know there there's
there's two views about something like
this one is these are obviously foreign
trolls because the english is such a
disaster
the other side of it is unfortunately
there are people who write adults who
write like this in the united states and
that is
a really really sad commentary
on the state of education in the united
states and i don't mean teachers are bad
but just the ability of your average
person i mean this is
is this considered
partial illiteracy is this so bad that
we we actually this is a this is a sort
of
partial illiteracy if someone writes
like this i don't know
i don't know but it's certainly very
very scary
you can write to me info
davidpakman.com remember just writing to
me doesn't guarantee that your email
will be chosen but it is info
davidpakman.com you can also sign up for
the bonus show an extra show every day
at joinpacman.com
sign up today it's a beautiful day
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman